how's it going braces sorry
I don't know why I keep doing it so I
got blue hair now I don't know how
that's gonna look with the green screen
I probably just end up looking more like
a tool than I already am choose my
barbarian okay Shana
the warrior princess or Rohan
the Barbarian those awesome giant Edith
Shain and she thank you thank you thank
you thank you oh my god this is so
[ __ ] good oh oh this is some good
[ __ ] that's what I'm talking about oh
she's changed her bra now what the [ __ ]
ah hey Bea huh Oh titties how did you
even see your titties I gonna pee in the
water a little bit and we're ready to do
this this is awkward as [ __ ] ah ah back
hey titties okay let's not go inside the
giant hole again ah we cool all right
we're cool my god let's pee on these
skulls there we go all done need to get
up here quality all right don't don't
don't
oh that was close Bob go through and not
jump our first enema Bratz wine jump
attack ow
he pushed me how dare you push me that's
right very attractive face let me pee on
it
there we go let's go oh my god the
graphics look at my titties but just
kidding you're dead ahh oh we're
fighting we're fighting this is so epic
Game of the Year anyone yes I think yes
and we get is very name any many
waterfalls that d'etat
no no no no no no no no no no no no not
all again oh my god oh damn look at that
what motor side what the [ __ ] was that
oh if we break we broke the game bill to
fall
I love the waterfall what is love
there's supposed to be three people
playing this but I don't have any
friends so don't do it my own
ah ah ah ah ah ladies laughs baby don't
hurt me
that's it putting more I I heard a lot
about this game there's a twist to it
all right more right there's the bet
talked to boy yes now you just stay home
to mama need to stay close to mama
she'll worry that I'll run off yeah
stupid haircut I am NOT I should not be
talking sometimes daddy let us Pat the
sheep on the head they're so soft okay
thank you for sharing adventure wow this
is exciting isn't it where's the Sheep
there you are
Oh
oh that one said bear oh my god how many
different sized sheep samples for
different sheep samples look at this we
have a legend let's go to the king hey
gimme what do you want did my brother
sent you blessin you should take this
knife who knows who me you may need it
all right
I don't see anything bad from this oh my
god I'm lost
what is this there's a book on top of
the pedestal it's labeled farmers
there's a list of names inside ladies
man 2 1 7 man I love ladies man 2 1 7
they didn't tell me it was a horror game
I hear ya just go over here you know no
big deal a farmer approaches why do you
have blood on your overalls this is
jelly from my donut yeah you know I'll
buy that what have you done I killed
that woman you are looking for uh Joe
stabbed nice - hey um I got it
no she looks so sad I came here to in my
life my name is Julia I want to see my
child in husband in heaven boy helped me
he helped me in my life you've done it
before he could be easier this time
please no [ __ ] you I'm not gonna do
leave me be Gary alright are we going
out then whoops sorry dead guy hmm his
name is ladies man t17 I murdered ladies
men t17
but you still
okay now tipple [ __ ] are you
why do you have blood on your bras i
shat my face why do you have a knife
it's not a knife it's okay it's a knife
why are you gonna do bout it
let me see what happened to you and
that's where this story shall end at
least for now
it is up to the next player of the game
to choose your fate
just as you choose for the previous play
40 PI so if you brought to play this
after don't count me you will be emailed
about your fate
that's pretty awesome alright so of a
couple days later I got the results it
says here as you left the cave you were
confronted by farmer cold lakhs stupid
name they ask you two questions the
first question was why do you have blood
on your rolls in which you responded i
shat my face that makes sense the second
question was asked why do you have a
knife in which you responded it's not a
knife it's okay to not worry after
hearing your answer
Lexx decided to kill you what with with
a knife received from the woodchopper
which goes to show that karma is alive
and well as you choose to kill previous
farmer ladies man to 1/7
rest in peace ladies men to 1/7